[Music]
this is Tesla's model 3 sedan and it's
the cheapest Tesla Model in China and
this is byd's Sil sedan it looks very
similar and it's one of the company's
most expensive models but with this
range china-based byd has closed in on
Tesla's share of the EV Market in China
China accounts for more than half of all
EVS sold globally in 2022 and any
company that can own this Market will
have an advantage on dominating the
growing industry there's a potential
here for new General Motors for new
Fords to emerge and for China to be a
dominant player we compared byd and
Tesla's business strategy Technology and
Manufacturing to understand whose
position to win
to see byd's rapid growth in China just
look at retail sales charts byd which is
backed by Warren Buffett jumped from
13th Place in 2021 to the top spot in
2022 in that time its overall sales more
than tripled hitting 1.86 million cars
that's some half a million more cars
than Tesla we have a lot of respect for
the car companies in China they are the
most competitive in the world in terms
of volume the top car company producing
EVS in China is definitely byd the
caveat is that it's not a cool EV brand
yet and that's why they introduce a new
series of cars with specs that car
commentators would say matching Tesla's
model 3. so while this seal sedan sells
for roughly thirty thousand dollars some
byd models sell for half that with most
models having an all-electric or plug-in
hybrid option their strategy is really
to ensure that consumers have options
Tesla's Fleet on the other hand is all
electric unlike byd it's mainly
positioned as a premium vehicle a
revolutionary bet from the beginning
there was kind of a belief among
traditional car companies that somebody
who would want an electric car was going
to be motivated by economic concerns the
cost of gasoline their thesis was let's
start at the top let's make a cool a
sexy car that appeals to luxury buyers
for the most part that bet has paid off
if you look at each company's profit
margins you can see Tesla exceeds byd
the company sells less vehicles with a
higher profit margin but in early 2023
Tesla slashed prices for its two most
popular electric car models reducing
prices in China by as much as 13 the
company said the cuts were possible
through engineering Innovations and cost
controls but these Cuts also came just
before China began withdrawing
decades-long subsidies for Ev buyers
it's time now for the market to become
more mature smaller companies that were
not profitable but who depended on these
subsidies need to be able to do more to
stand on their own Tesla might have the
marketing power to whether the subsidy
crash but byd has its own strength
reduction specifically battery
production this is just a sample of some
businesses that byd operates as you can
see it's far more vertically integrated
byd has three main areas of business it
produces cars it produces batteries for
its car and it also produces chips
before byd was an electric vehicle
company its main focus was batteries and
this battery branch of its business
ensures stability along the supply chain
even while disruptions plagued its
competitors compare that to Tesla which
continues to Source the majority of its
batteries from outside suppliers there's
been this tension around Tesla from the
get-go over its ability to get cells the
idea was to be buying so many of them
from suppliers that they would have
pricing advantage and they could get the
cost down it hasn't come down as much as
they wanted or much as they thought but
it has come down dramatically although
the US government is investing in this
area of business even producing the raw
and intermediate ingredients that
compose battery cells requires
Outsourcing when you think about where
the ingredients for these cells come
from it's largely a China game at this
point I think about lithium something
like 70 percent of it is refined in
China it's kind of worrisome to people
here in the U.S byd uses its own blade
battery which is a lithium iron
phosphate battery known as lfp the lfp
battery is the primary EV battery in
China and is generally viewed as a
cheaper option since it doesn't use the
costly elements nickel and Cobalt but it
comes with a trade-off the batteries
range range is a real issue for U.S
consumers there is this mindset that
there just might be a reason why you
need to go 300 miles or more in a trip
and so that's one of the the big kind of
differences between the China and the US
market in line with Market preference
Tesla's standard range models in China
also use an lfp battery its version is
made by Chinese maker catl but its long
range models still use an NCM based
battery that's nickel Cobalt manganese
some even include aluminum it's more
expensive but can charge a car for
longer distances and in the US Tesla
primarily uses this type of battery but
this may be changing Tesla is taking a
page out of the Chinese Market's
Playbook using lfp batteries in lower
cost models so even as Tesla invests in
its own battery production in the U.S
it'll still depend on Chinese resources
for some time
the final challenge for Ev makers is
getting their cars where their consumers
are eyd has a home-based advantage in
the China Market but Tesla has gained
some with this Factory in Shanghai built
in 2019 this was the first of its kind
for Tesla and frankly for any foreign
automaker it got off the ground rather
quickly in large part because of the
support from the the local Chinese
government they wanted to help Tesla get
going the local government in Shanghai
granted Tesla a corporate income tax
rate of 15 percent through 2023 a
significantly lower rate than the
standard 25 percent the factory deal
helps slash production costs for cars
sold in the country and Tesla was also
able to get out of a joint venture
agreement for years if you were General
Motors or you were a Volkswagen and you
wanted to build cars in China you had to
share the profit you had to share the
running of that joint venture and Tesla
didn't want to give up that kind of
control today Tesla sells in over 30
countries with manufacturing plants in
the U.S China and Germany byd D having
taken over China is just beginning its
Global push its passenger EVS are
currently for sale in China and a
handful of other countries the US is not
yet one of those in part because of the
U.S China tensions right now it's hard
for any Chinese car company to say
they're making a far into the U.S market
right now it's also hard for car
companies to just think about expanding
into Market by exporting their purely
without manufacturing locally the fight
for the global EV Market has a ways to
go in China the market needs to mature
on its own without government subsidies
while the U.S needs to dramatically
improve its supply chain in the country
and up its EB adoption rate as for the
companies themselves byd has yet to
fully articulate its plans to enter the
U.S passenger EV Market while China's
biggest Evie maker faces pressure to
expand uid said customer satisfaction is
its main goal and top priority I've been
writing about the automotive industry
for almost 20 years and there's always
been this kind of belief that the
Chinese car companies were on the verge
of coming to the states we haven't
really seen that yet creating the
infrastructure to sell the vehicles is a
challenge Tesla did not respond to a
request for comment but the company also
faces its own obstacles ahead they need
to show growth to the investment
community and we have seen investors
really be forgiving at the idea of
chasing sales volume at the potential
cost of profitability if electric
vehicles are truly the future of the car
owning this Market could be Paramount to
a country's economy in order for that to
be a reality for Tesla EV batteries will
need to be made in America
foreign